James what an episode it is super
Bittersweet to be talking to you today
but how are you feeling now that
everything is played out everyone's seen
it it's done how are you feeling I mean
Jubilee is a relief like you know what's
happening on the show so now it's kind
of like I I have less questions to have
to answer from my friends and family so
it's good to see TV like you want to be
a part of these great episodes like if
you go out you wanted to be a blind side
you want to go out trying to make moves
so there's only gonna be one winner
unfortunately it wasn't me but this is
the game I signed up for so I'm really
excited to you know be here and kind of
move forward
well that's a great Outlook to have I
love the positivity so let's talk about
the episode and everything that went
down at tribal after you know Jeff told
you guys at the immunity challenge you'd
be splitting up into two two people
would be going home how did your
strategy change when you got that
information
I wanted to like you know be the same
person like I was playing a very much a
I'm saying this I'm doing this type game
so in being transparent about who I
wanted out being transparent about these
things like I felt like that was the
best way for me to say in the game
looking at that split tribal you had
three people you know who were trying to
make a move and Carl ahead of unity and
I was a person to make the move at the
end of the day it comes down to if Carla
you know wants to move with them it
doesn't matter what I do in that moment
so I'm just trying to maintain trust
with Carla build trust with Noel and
maintain trust with Sandy that I said
I'm gonna do this that's what I'm gonna
do and it's kind of one of the positions
where I I I was cutting you're cutting
half and I had to you know that's that's
the decision I made yeah so it
definitely was a blind side you were
definitely shocked you could tell you
were visibly upset even though you're
like great move great move
um visibly upset understandably so
um so let's talk about noelle's plan she
told you that she was going to steal
Owen's vote obviously it was a smoke
screen for what ended up happening how
confident were you going into tribal
thinking that Owen was going to be the
one going
so like I'm a really logical player and
sometimes your logic and your social
gets in the way of it for me I looked at
it like if you're going to use your
syllable and Carla's in on the plan
right there's no need to use unless you
really are trying to like get in good
because you're not the target of this
vote and you have your syllable going
into the eight Mickey is super valuable
so like if you're gonna use it now
you're really trying to play together so
yeah I believed it so I mean and the
fact that you did it you burned an
advantage
did it put me at rest yes but at the
same time I didn't plan on taking her
advantage
that at all so it kind of is what it is
but I mean it's a good gameplay it did
have me very calm and and chill and also
just the game that we were playing where
I thought I was a good shield in the
game beating all those are coming on me
so far so now I'm out the game now the
target is going to be who's the next
Target so I think it makes for a fun
game moving forward
yeah absolutely now
um when you their plan clearly worked
and you know you also speaking of
advantages you walked away with your
knowledge as power Advantage you didn't
use it was there ever a moment in the
game that you were kind of considering
using it or even at that tribal uh no
there wasn't any time in the game at
that point that I considered using the
advantage it was too many people I feel
like the second you use it if you use it
incorrectly and you don't get something
it's easy to have a live tribal vote
that guy out like if you usually you get
something it's like oh you have an idol
oh well let's vote this guy out like I I
don't like I feel like you can burn it
if you have somebody that's going to
minority and they don't have anybody and
you get it's almost like an idle
nullifier in a way but I don't know I I
don't know a good like it depends it's
really situational and you want to hope
that no one knows you have it so I
didn't have any of any of those uh
things happen for me and you know part
of that is kind of you know really I
could have took the advantage and ran
away and but everybody thought it was
obvious power so even if it wasn't
that's how late people were playing so
yeah absolutely so in that moment when
you got sent home and you had to go and
sit on the jury right away who in your
head even now looking back who do you
think was playing the strongest game
so I feel like
um like that is one of those tricky
questions we're just kind of like okay
so strong game meaning get it to the end
or strong game making moves like I feel
like when you're when no one is saying
your name you are hurt you're playing a
strong game so I feel like Jesse Cody
Carla gabler like no one is saying
anybody else's name at this present
moment so now we're going to see kind of
what happens when names start getting
thrown out there
um and I I mean I feel like everybody's
playing great for the most part like you
don't know like you it's really open so
from an outside player looking in you
don't know how this is going to break
even as opposed to if you know the quote
unquote seven or six or five keep it
together it kind of looks like a
belonging about to happen and people
would hate the football game so I mean
but I think everybody's playing their
own game and there's no such thing as a
perfect game in the minor Survivor you
have to get to the end and make an
argument to the jury and I feel like you
can't just sit there and say I could
beat this person I can beat this person
it's like every everybody thought they
could be Marianne and look what happened
everybody thought it could probably be
Erica look what happened like this like
you don't have this surgery that people
think that they have but we'll see what
happens we will see what happens and you
know although your Survivor Journey
didn't end how you wanted it to would
you say that it was like everything that
you pictured it to be
like you wake up to these beautiful
sunrises and sunsets I get the scheme
plot live build lifelong friendships
meet cool people
um it's like I thoroughly enjoyed this
experience I mean it's like when it when
it's over you're like I mean I'll I'll
stay again like I'll play like I'll play
like let me know so I feel like it was a
great time it was a great experience and
um it was good to meet the people and I
play the game that I love
amazing well it was so lovely chatting
with you thank you so much for your time
and I'm looking forward to seeing you on
the jury and seeing how all of this
plays out
hey we'll see we will see